und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend mehr als 1300 positiv
getestete sind es inzwischen bei
turniers wie kann dieser größere neue
corona ausbruch in deutschland
eingedämmt und beherrscht werden damit
daraus kein nordrhein westfälisches
ischgl wird ministerpräsident armin
laschet zeigte sich heute zuversichtlich
dass das gelingen kann auch ohne einen
lock down für gütersloh und umgebung
solche flächen deckenden maßnahmen soll
es vorerst nicht geben
das wirft fragen auf die ich ihm gleich
selbst stelle
doch zunächst thomas münten mit einem
aktuellen lagebericht aus westfalen
das ist heute sommerlich heißen den
billig wohnung in den weg und trotzdem
können sie höchstens vor die tür kommen
rund 7000 mitarbeiter sitzen in
quarantäne
hinter bauzäunen inzwischen überwacht
von ordnungsämtern und polizei aber
sofort finanziert tönnies corona tests
für alle menschen im kreis gütersloh
allein von den bisher getesteten sind
über 1300 positiv und das ist wie es war
wichtig dass in der heimatsprache mit
den menschen geredet wird dass sie keine
angst haben müssen dass für die
versorgung gesichert ist dass man ihn
klar machte haub nicht ab sonst steckt
ihr eure leute zu hause an
das war den sagt braucht keiner angst
haben wird wenn ihr geredet werdet ihr
gut medizinisch versorgt wie viele sich
vorher nach hause abgesetzt haben das
lässt sich immer noch nicht sagen
es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass es
menschen gibt die auch im möglicherweise
angeschlagenen kranken zustand den kreis
gütersloh verlassen haben und nach hause
gefahren sind in ihrer heimat auch das
muss man raus kriegen denn das ist ja
eigentlich eine ganz ganz schlimme
entwicklung der ehemalige nrw
justizminister thomas kutschaty heute
oppositionsführer im landtag ist da
skeptisch ich habe erhebliche zweifel
dass dieses problem noch regional zu
begrenzen ist weit über 1000 infizierte
im augenblick die hatten in den letzten
wochen massive viele kontakte auch
außerhalb des kreises hinaus des weges
jetzt ein konsequentes handeln der
landesregierung geboren in gütersloh
protestierten heute früh tierschützer
firmenchef clemens tönnies ist nach
seinem kurzauftritt gestern wieder
abgetaucht das tischtuch zwischen ihm
und dem gesundheitsminister wohl
zerschnitten wo der mindestlohn zur
debatte stand ja die fleischindustrie
dafür ihre von tönnies gesagt mach kein
mindestlohn wir machen eine freiwillige
vereinbarung
da kam der mindestlohn da mussten wir
feststellen dass auf einmal die leute
ihre werkzeuge selber bezahlen müssen
und jetzt stehen wir vor dem nächsten
schritt
und jetzt gibt es eben kann die
zwischenschritte mehr meiner meinung in
dieser phase ist abgeschlossen mit der
fleischwirtschaft kann es keine
freiwilligen vereinbarung geben das muss
klare gesetzliche regelung geben die in
ganz deutschland gelten außerhalb des
mitarbeiter umfeldes gibt es im kreis
gütersloh nur 16 bisher bekannte
neuinfektionen
deshalb hat die landesregierung bisher
auf einen generellen lockdown in der
region verzichtet völlig ungelöst ist
das problem der bauern die ihre
schlachtreifen schweine nicht absetzen
können
diese problematik wird sich bis mitte
der woche erheblich verschärfen
das gilt auch für die mehr als 1300
quarantäne wohnungen wenn die
temperaturen in den nächsten tagen immer
höher steigen
tja und jetzt von armin laschet
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
zugeschaltet aus aachen guten abend herr
laschet nahm slomka erleichtert es gibt
ja eigentlich diese verabredung zwischen
bund und länder diesen notfall
mechanismus wenn die zahl der
neuinfektionen über 50 pro 100000
einwohner steigt warum greift er jetzt
nicht warum kein lockdown für gütersloh
und umgebung
ja der greift so wie wir das genau
verabredet haben
wie wird es in anderen fällen auch schon
gehandhabt haben das dann wenn das
ereignissen lokalisierbar ist man erst
einmal alles tun muss damit die ursache
beseitigt wird das haben wir durch die
quarantäne
die wir jetzt für 7000 menschen
verordnet haben durchgesetzt und das ist
schon ein ambitiöses ziel denn die
menschen müssen mit essen versorgt
werden man muss ihnen auch in ihrer
muttersprache erklären was eigentlich
das problem ist und wir werden
polizeikräfte und kräfte des
ordnungsamtes einsetzen damit dieser
teil umgesetzt wird der zweite wir haben
die schulen und kitas geschlossen das
ist der erste teil eines lockdown und
wir werden weitere schritte in diesen
tagen prüfen deshalb war ich ja mit dem
gesundheitsminister heute doch dann
hatte es vor ort von den experten die
lage berichten
das haben wir auch in dem bericht
gesehen und steht da in dieser
vereinbarung zwischen bund und länder
bei einem verteilten regionalen
ausbruchsgeschehen und unklaren
infektionsketten muss es um allgemeine
beschränkungen geben das gilt nur für
eingrenzbar hre infektion da dachte man
ein altenheim aber das was ich bei tunis
abspielt mit 1300 leute die quer
verstreut durch die region wohnen das
ist doch eigentlich das was man als ein
verteiltes regionales ausbruchsgeschehen
bezeichnet wie wollen sie kontrollieren
dass die wirklich die infizierten in
quarantäne sind und sich noch niemand
anders in gütersloh angesteckt hat ja
das eine die quarantäne wird jetzt
durchgesetzt sie haben sogar bilder
gesehen von dem einen ortsteil wo sogar
eingezäunt worden ist eine unterkunft
also ein sehr sehr massives mittel und
ich habe heute abend nachdem ich dort in
gütersloh war noch mal mit sehr vielen
experten gesprochen mit denen die vor
ort sind dass erica i hat ebenfalls drei
experten entsandt die jetzt die kette
nachverfolgen
die werden uns in den nächsten tagen
einen bericht liefern und ich kann
diesen lockdown nicht ausschließen er
muss nur gezielt sein er muss begründet
sein und er muss das ziel erreichen dass
sich die infektion nicht weiter in die
bevölkerung verbreitet
in hansell keine entwarnung heute
sondern den rat der experten der
virologen der epidemiologen der
hygieniker ab wachsen und die haben mir
heute abend auch versprochen
der bericht kommt in den nächsten tagen
in hamm 40 kilometer von oslo entfernt
waren nach drei kinder von john hughes
mitarbeitern die sich bei ihren eltern
infiziert haben in den schulen auch in
der grundschule diese schulen wurden
jetzt geschlossen
woher weiß man dass die nicht schon
längst vorher in den tagen was infiziert
haben also dass weiter getragen haben ja
das ja das werden uns halt die
lka-experten auch sagen
in der tat haben sie haben angesprochen
es gab in bielefeld fälle es gibt im
kreis warendorf fälle
es gibt dem kreis gütersloh fälle und
gibt es gibt in einem anderen teil des
kreises gütersloh so gut wie keine
neuinfektionen
deshalb will ich dass wir sehr
zielgerichtet sehr konsequent dann
handeln wenn wir die nötigen
informationen haben zum beispiel war
geplant die testungen der genius
mitarbeiter erst am 24 juni also am
donnerstag abzuschließen wir haben mit
hilfe der bundeswehr über das wochenende
geschafft alle 7000 zu testen und morgen
geht der nächste schritt weiter dann
werden wir uns auf altenheime und andere
einrichtungen konzentrieren um jede
wechselwirkung auszuschließen aber es
muss auf fundierter wissenschaftlicher
basis passieren und das haben wir auch
heute mit dem krisenstab so besprochen
wissenschaftler betonen immer wieder wie
schnell dieses virus sich ausbreiten
dass man es bereits hat bevor man es
überhaupt merkt das heißt dass es da
jetzt zum beispiel moment in gütersloh
nur 16 infektionen gibt sagt überhaupt
nichts darüber aus was sich tatsächlich
in der bevölkerung in gütersloh abspielt
und einige scheinen ja auch von den
bergarbeitern sich bereits nach wie sagt
man im rheinland für die visiert zu
haben weiß man wo die ihm gereift sind
wo die das virus hin tragen
ob das so ist weiß man nicht man hat das
geschlossen aus denen essenslieferungen
die man bringen wollte wo weniger
menschen da waren als man vermutet hatte
es gab auch den eigentlich nicht
akzeptablen vorgang dass wir bis gestern
dass das örtliche amt überhaupt nicht
die namen und die adresse aller
mitarbeiter gehabt hat das ist in der
dann sichergestellt worden so dass wir
heute einen schritt weiter sind aber ich
will davor warnen zu glauben die
situation sei gelöst man muss stündlich
neue informationen sammeln und dann auch
da wo es geht konsequent handeln bei
schulen und geht das wie gesagt hat
begonnen
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wir
kontakt beschränkungen ebenfalls wieder
erlassen so wie sie im lockdown gegolten
haben
aber manche schildern uns das ist noch
einkäufe in supermärkten an dem beispiel
können sie sehen
stelle hinter ferenc seien nicht denn
auch im lockdown ja nein auch im
lockdown den wir ja im märz in ganz
deutschland hatten ist natürlich die
lebensmittelversorgung für die
bevölkerung fortgesetzt worden
deshalb muss man mittel finden
zielgerichtet jetzt maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
aber herr lasse ich denke dass wir
morgen und übermorgen da mehr wissen in
diesem lockdown waren alle sehr viel
vorsichtiger und die ganze bevölkerung
war vorsichtig man gehen wirklich
eigentlich nur zum einkaufen raus und
auch nur alleine also die ganze
kommunikation im märz für eine andere
als die lockerungs kommunikation und
eine frage hätte ich noch da sie gerade
auch noch mal die schulen ansprachen wie
passt das denn eigentlich dazu dass ihre
schulminister immer betont schulen sei
überhaupt kein problem da gab es
praktisch kein infektionsrisiko bei
kindern nicht infektiös sein verstehe
ich nicht so ganz
das sagt nicht unsere schule werden das
ja da hat lexus ministerkonferenz für
alle für alle kultur haben sie bezieht
sich auf informationen die alle 16
kultusminister in deutschland dazu
gebracht haben zu sagen wir müssen nach
den ferien wieder mit dem regel
schulbetrieb beginnen wir haben hier
nordrhein westfalen vor drei wochen die
kitas geöffnet und es gibt so gut wie
überhaupt keine fälle die da ein problem
werden das ist halt in diesen
schwierigen tagen immer eine abwägung
gibt man den kindern das recht auf
bildung gibt man den eltern die chance
auf betreuung und im kreis gütersloh
marschieren im moment die eltern voller
wut vor die firmenzentrale und sagen
jetzt ist das was wir hier als chance
hatten das wieder betreuung und
unterricht für die kinder statt
findet jetzt ist das zerstört worden
durch einen missstand in diesem
fleischereibetrieb also sie sehen da
muss man vieles abwägen wir haben uns
entschieden das risiko für die kinder
und jugendlichen klein zu halten weil
auch unter den familien natürlich kinder
und jugendliche waren ansonsten ihr
bericht hat gezeigt es gibt 16
übertragungen in die bevölkerung morgen
und übermorgen wissen wir mehr
und noch einmal meine einschätzung
keiner soll glauben es gäbe keinen
lockdown müssen es nur zielgerichtet
nach und sehen ob es bei diesem 16
bleiben wird und die sind ja auch eher
ein blick in die vergangenheit herr
laschet
danke für das gespräch nach angaben des
landkreises sind übrigens mindestens
fünf turniers mitarbeiter bereits so
schwer erkrankt dass sie auf
intensivstationen liegen
das sind arbeiter keine alten leute also
das virus ist unberechenbar auch bei den
schäden die sie anrichten kann man weiß
zwar immer noch zu wenig eine
chinesische studie stellte kürzlich zb
veränderungen in der lunge fest auch bei
jungen infizierten die sich nicht krank
fühlten außerdem berichten kliniken auch
in deutschland von patienten bei denen
das virus offenbar das gehirn befallen
hat mit schäden die auch nicht einfach
nach zwei drei wochen wieder weggehen
von natürlich aus der frontal21
redaktion hat darüber mit ärzten und
betroffenen gesprochen
sie hatte sich auf dem kreuzfahrtschiff
in der karibik mit corona infiziert
zurück in deutschland konnte er sie lud
man im krankenhaus noch ein not
testament aufsetzen dann musste sie
beatmet werden
dann bin ich wohl ins koma versetzt
worden
und 26 tage später wieder aufgebaut
die lungenentzündung hat sie überlebt zu
schaffen aber macht ihr das gedächtnis
die 66-jährige vergisst ganze wörter
musste jeden einzelnen buchstaben neu
lernen
also ich habe natürlich angst dass es
von kobe kommt professor peter berlitz
liegen erste mrt bilder von coop 19
patienten vor die zeigen dass das neue
corona virus auch das gehirn gefällt es
dort das potenzial wichtige
steuerungsprozesse wie das atemzentrum
lahmzulegen
dort gibt es eben diese ersten hinweise
darauf dass eine besondere affinität
besteht eben zum atem steuerungs zentrum
und wenn dort ein viraler besiedlung ein
viraler infekt auftritt besteht das
risiko dass eben das automatische atmen
nicht mehr funktioniert genau das hat
lotte abels erlebt die 34-jährige
mathematikerinnen hat die erkrankung der
lunge schon im märz april zuhause
durchgemacht wochen später leidet sie
unter gedächtnisverlust kann sich weder
konzentrieren noch lesen ohne dass es
ihr übel wird auch sie hat das virus im
verdacht das erste das war dann schon
ein bisschen gruselig war dass ich dann
irgendwann festgestellt habe dass meine
atmung zwischendurch stoppt es gibt
berichte von kogit patienten versterben
ohne zuvor jungen symptome entwickelt zu
haben viele mediziner können sich das
nur mit einer beteiligung des gehirns
erklären und wollen das jetzt
untersuchen was uns im moment große
schwierigkeiten macht ist zu verstehen
warum viele patienten ohne schwere
lungen beteiligung schon sehr frühzeitig
in ein stadium geraten dass sie selber
nicht mehr luft holen können also ein
atem antriebsstörungen haben die akute
erkrankung der lunge hat esel ob man
überlegt aber bekommt sie auf ihr
gedächtnis zurück demnächst wird sie aus
der reha nach hause entlassen
aber ist sie korrekt 19 auch wirklich
schon los 14 tagen bin ich in
hausärztlicher behandlung und ich sehe
schon dass abgetan wird ja das wird
schon alles deutschland gibt milliarden
aus und seine bevölkerung vor corona zu
schützen aber über die langzeitfolgen
von coop 19 wissen mediziner noch immer
zu wenig ein weiteren durch dort so gibt
es am dienstag in frontal 21
außerdem bieten die kollegen von zdf
heute viele informationen rund um das
thema corona an
doch der erwerb wieder ansteigt zum
beispiel oder wer die neue corona apps
besonders oft herunterlädt
corinna zeiten wird das reisen auch
anders sein aber viele bürger freuen
sich natürlich auf die sommer
frieren auch flugreisen sind ja wieder
möglich fragt sich nur ob sich tausende
kunden die bis heute ihr geld von
stornierten flügen aus dem frühjahr
nicht zurückbekommen haben jetzt schon
wieder lust haben auf neue buchungen
auch die lufthansa hat ihre kunden
bisher nur vertröstet
verbraucherschützer sind darüber empört
dass recht ist auf seiten der kunden nur
nutzt einen das offenbar nicht viel
die verärgerung ist umso größer als sich
zu gleicher die steuerzahler mit 9
milliarden an der rettung der lufthansa
beteiligen sollen dieser deal mit der
bundesregierung steht aber im moment
noch auf der kippe
lufthansa-chef spur spricht davon dass
man vor einer schicksalswoche stehe und
das gilt vor allem für seine mitarbeiter
dominik löschmeister berichtet michael
flea schütz und marlies rose sind
lufthanseaten 30 jahre und mehr arbeiten
sie bei der lufthansa bodencrew in
hamburg dort treffen wir sie in einem
café an der landebahn erst seit kurzem
wissen sie dass sie und ihre kollegen
von der bodengruppe ende september die
kündigung bekommen
jahrzehnte hat man gesagt ihr seid
lufthansa ihr müsst hinter der firma
stehen und das sind können wir nun und
nun sind wir halt nicht mehr gefragt
eigentlich hatte die lufthansa den rund
100 mitarbeitern an der station in
hamburg das angebot gemacht in frankfurt
oder münchen weiter zu machen viele
waren bereit dazu doch mit dem corona
sparpaket wurde das zurückgezogen
hinzu kommt jetzt die sorge vor einer
insolvenz der lufthansa wenn das
staatliche rettungspaket scheitert für
uns wäre der supergau weil viele
kollegen und kolleginnen stehen wirklich
kurz vor der rente sich selber ja auch
und viele andere männer kollegen und
kolleginnen altersteilzeit und wenn
ihnen also der boden unter den füßen
weggezogen wird und dann vor allen
dingen mit cobo nach oben
wir haben auf dem arbeitsmarkt ja alle
keine chancen 11.000 jobs sind in
deutschland so viel an bord der kranich
airline lufthansa chef spur kämpfte in
den vergangenen wochen an vielen fronten
mit den gewerkschaften verhandelt er
aktuell noch äußern dazu will er sich
öffentlich nicht in einem internen brief
aber schreibt er heute an die
mitarbeiter unser ziel im vorstand
bleibt selbstverständlich eine insolvenz
mit all ihren folgen zu vermeiden wir
tragen und spüren gerade in diesen tagen
die verantwortung für sie unsere 138000
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter auf der
ganzen welt
noch ist nicht sicher ob die aktionäre
der mühsam verhandelten
staatsbeteiligung zustimmen entscheidend
wird das abstimmungsverhalten von heinz
hermann thiele sein dem neuen
großaktionär der lufthansa eine
insolvenz hätte fatale folgen
die lufthansa als internationaler global
pr würde global an dem der schaden
erleiden dass die reputation der fast
das vertrauen das die lufthansa hat im
markt maßgeblich zerstört werde
henning pro kopf dass es nicht dazu
kommt dass es irgendwie weitergeht seit
märz ist er nicht mehr geflogen als
flugbegleiter für die lufthansa tochter
germanwings ihr aus ist bereits
verkündet was aus den beschäftigten wird
wissen sie nicht die stimmung ist auf
jeden fall total unsicher wir kollegen
ja wir sind auf der einen seite traurig
dass wir nicht mehr fliegen können aber
natürlich dann auch total verunsichert
wie es mit uns in zukunft weitergeht es
ist die woche der entscheidung für die
lufthansa klappt die rettung durch den
staat oder rutscht deutschlands größte
airline in einer insolvenz und jetzt
macht erstmal heinz wolf weiter in
großbritannien stufen die
sicherheitsbehörden den messerangriff in
einem ort in der nähe von london als
terrorakt ein
drei menschen wurden getötet drei schwer
verletzt der täter griff seine opfer in
einem park in der stadt redding an und
stach auf sie ein
der angreifer konnte festgenommen werden
ermittler durchsuchten seine wohnung
über sein konkretes motiv und weitere
hintergründe
noch nichts bekannt in serbien haben die
bürger ein neues parlament gewählt
mehrere oppositionsparteien traten aus
protest nicht zur wahl an sie werfen
präsident alexander witsch einen
zunehmend autokratischen regierungsstil
und eine einschränkung der wahlfreiheit
vor die rechtsnationale serbische
fortschrittspartei von präsident bush
hat die wahl laut ersten hochrechnungen
haushoch gewonnen angesichts der hohen
zustimmung im land zu den getroffenen
corona maßnahmen war die beliebtheit der
regierungspartei zuletzt deutlich
gestiegen russland und die usa
verhandeln wieder über die atomare
abrüstung die gespräche beginnen morgen
in wien
russland hat zuletzt druck gemacht mit
beratungen zu beginnen
der new start vertrag der die begrenzung
strategischer kernwaffen regelt läuft
anfang kommenden jahres aus und der enev
vertrag zu kurz und mittelstrecken
systemen war im vergangenen sommer
aufgekündigt worden
us präsident donald trump wollte nach
der krone bedingten pause seinem
wahlkampf neuen schwung verleihen
es kamen jedoch weniger besucher als
erhofft zu seiner großveranstaltung in
tauscha trump war auf deutschland in
seiner rede erneut vor zu wenig für
verteidigung auszugeben
zur corona krise sagte traum wenn
langsamer getestet würde würden die
fallzahlen in den usa nicht so schnell
steigen
eine sprecherin sagte später dass zwei
als scherz gemeint gewesen
so etwas habe er in 46 dienstjahren als
polizist noch nicht erlebt sagte
stuttgarts polizeipräsident auch dem auf
der pressekonferenz neben ihm sitzenden
oberbürgermeister fritz kuhn stand noch
der schock ins gesicht geschrieben dass
die stuttgarter party szene immer wieder
mal auch aggressiv auf polizisten
reagiert ist nicht neu aber was sich
vergangene nacht abspielte war
beispiellos vor allem die wucht der
zerstörungswut uns gewaltbereitschaft
die bilder ähneln zum teil den
gewaltorgien von hooligans zum teil den
g-20 ausschreitungen in hamburg einen
politischen hintergrund schließt die
stuttgarter polizei bislang aber aus sie
spricht von randalierern und einem
bunten nationale
hätten nichts sandra susanka berichte
richtig feiern
corona bedingt ist das momentan nur
draußen möglich auch in stuttgart sind
die klubs noch geschlossen
vergangene nacht eskaliert eine
drogenkontrolle bei einem 17-jährigen
und löst damit eine welle der gewalt aus
die man hier noch nicht erlebt hat mit
diesem ganz normalen für uns üblichen
einschreiten haben sich sofort zwei bis
dreihundert anwesende personen dort aus
sag ich mal aus der partyszene und
freitags abends samstagabend szene
solidarisieren haben sofort die
polizeibeamten vor ort massiv
angegriffen mit steinen und flaschen
dürfen die bilder die in den sozialen
medien kursieren zeigen die brutalität
gegen die polizei bis zu 500 menschen
randalieren in der stuttgarter
innenstadt 19 beamte werden dabei
verletzt
dutzend der gewalttätige kleingruppen
zerstören plündern es trifft 40
geschäfte
die polizei braucht über fünf stunden um
der lage herr zu werden nimmt 24
personen fest
politische motive stecken nicht hinter
den ausschreitungen sagt die polizei am
tag danach die party und eventszene die
wir in stuttgart haben eine gruppe von
menschen die hat sich seit vier wochen
wieder getroffen in der öffentlichkeit
was ganz neu dazu kommen sie inszeniert
sich dann in den sozialen medien mit
ihrem handeln und da gehört seit
neuestem eben auch dazu ein aggressives
und beleidigendes tun gegen
polizeibeamte eine partyszene die
scheinbar keine grenzen kennt und bei
der sich in der korona zeit wohl viel
frust und trug aufgestaut hat gestern
entlädt er sich
polizei hat versucht also wir haben
versucht polizei gewalt auszuüben
der jugendliche war dagegen und ich sage
euch ehrlich und dann haben wir gesehen
wie ein typ mit grauem pullover in
mcdonough reingeht die kasse rausreißt
und dann weggerannt
für mich ist das erste mal so richtig
schockierend in stuttgart dass sich das
live erleben darf oberbürgermeister
fritz kuhn glaubt nicht dass es in
stuttgart eine höhere gewaltbereitschaft
gebe als anderswo aber er setzt auch ein
klares statement ich appelliere an alle
die vielleicht glauben dass man durch
ein bisschen alkohol und weiß im youtube
kommt so etwas darf so etwas ist in
unser stadt nicht akzeptabel und deshalb
sollen in den nächsten wochen deutlich
mehr polizisten durch die innenstadt
patroullieren zur abschreckung und
nochmal heinz mit weiteren nachrichten
des tages
in spanien ist der wegen der korona
pandemie ausgerufene notstand nach 14
wochen wieder aufgehoben
die bürger dürfen sich wieder frei im
ganzen land bewegen
auch die grenzen sowie die flug- und
seehäfen sind für europäische reisende
weitgehend geöffnet mo die grenze zu
portugal bleibt vorerst geschlossen
heute vor 125 jahren wurde der nord
ostsee kanal eingeweiht von kaiser
wilhelm dem zweiten in kiel auf rund 100
kilometern verbindet der kanal die
beiden meeren
immer noch ist die meistbefahrene
künstliche wasserstraße der welt
wenn corinna sind die verkehrszahlen
jedoch um 30 prozent eingebrochen
außerdem wird aufgrund der pandemie die
große jubiläumsfeier auf das nächste
jahr verschoben
in indonesien ist der vulkan merapi
wieder ausgebrochen aus dem knapp 3000
meter hohen berg stiegen kilometer hohe
aschewolken auf die behörden forderten
die menschen auf die drei kilometer
gefahrenzone und
krater zu meiden der vulkan auf der
insel java gehört zu den aktivsten der
welt ein tropischer dschungel sehr
naturalistisch gemalt und vor allem mit
viel tiefe also bringt dreidimensional
und riesig groß ein wandbild nicht in
einer gemäldegalerie oder einem schloss
sondern ebenso das wird teil eines
geheges zimmer mit aussicht sozusagen
und viel kunstvoller als eine schnöde
fototapeten trio rahmen nennt man solche
kulissen nie beim bühnenbau fürs theater
wird ein ganzer raum gestaltet teils
gemalt und mit echten utensilien
baumstämmen et cetera kombiniert solche
illusionen zu erschaffen ist ein eigener
beruf und journal hat der künstler wer
diese szenerie geschaffen hat christhard
läpple hat ihn bei der arbeit im
berliner zoo beobachtet tatsächlich es
tut sich was im zoo
kein fake in berlin wird geackert
schöner wohnen für löwe tiger und co
das raubtier aus im zoologischen garten
wird von grund auf modernisiert mehr
freiraum für tiere weniger gefängnis
eine lebensaufgabe für uwe turner
das ziel ist es eigentlich die die
menschen irgendwie dazu zu bewegen dass
man ja die natur schützt sein beruf ist
eine neue welt zu erschaffen man könnte
auch sagen eine heile eine welt der
perfekten illusion an der berliner uwe
turner ist ein meister seines fachs bis
ins letzte detail letztendlich ist diese
malerei nachempfunden praktisch sibirien
dort hat man ein mischwald ähnlich wie
hier man könnte denken dass im grunewald
aber nicht fest
da kommt es ihm zu hängen das ist
vielleicht kommt ja das ist afro rat die
erste bewohnerin eine sibirische tigerin
gut dass es zum frühstück münchen gibt
die 13-jährige testet die neue komplett
künstliche zu landschaft es könnte so
auch in der natur seien ja dass das mit
den felsen mit dem hintergrund und mit
dem tiger das passt
sein vorbild die echte wilde natur
wunderschön und grausam einzigartig und
absolut gefährdet auf zahllosen reisen
durch afrika sammelte der gebürtige
berliner seine energie machte fotos
entwickelte ideen als schüler malte er
pausenlos tiere nach dem kunststudium
finger als schildermaler an berliner zoo
an
längst hat der 68-jährige in ganz europa
dioramen gebot hässliche käfige in
kleine naturparadiese verwandelt das ist
wirklich so wie der italiener sagt kripo
option also ein schuss ins auge und man
musste glicht erkennen und dann schatten
erkennen oder irgendwas aber hier zum
beispiel dass die kanten die muss
einfach heller werden nachher täuschend
echt mit zement und farbe mit geduld und
liebe zur illusionsmalerei natur aus und
das ist sein handwerk und virtuos großer
wunsch bedrohte natur ein stück wald zu
erhalten
von der gestaltung immer noch ein paar
bonbons die ich gerne mache
wir haben da ein aus zement einen
baumstumpf der in die malerei rein geht
und so kriegt das auch wieder einen
gewissen charme weist sage es mal so
nun fehlen nur noch die lösen und ein
bisschen aufrollen müssen wir noch nach
dann könnte in diesem jahr noch das
raubtierhaus wieder eröffnet werden
aber die geschichte spielt ja in berlin
da ist wohl besser geduld angebracht
mal sehen was schnell eröffnet
raubtierhaus oder br nächste woche
jedenfalls definitiv noch nicht dafür
gibt es aber andere termine die bereits
feststehen jana becker hat einige
ereignisse zusammengestellt für unseren
sonntäglichen wochenausblick
[Musik]
der offizielle richter wechsel an der
spitze des bundesverfassungsgerichts
erfolgt am montag stephan harbarth
bisher vizepräsident und vorsitzender
des ersten senats wird morgen zum
fünften mann im staat ernannt der 48
jährige folgt auf andreas voßkuhle der
das amt zehn jahre lang bekleidet hatte
am mittwoch wird russland seine
jährliche militärparade nachholen das
land erinnert wie hier im vergangenen
jahr traditionsgemäß an dem sieg über
nazideutschland und an die 27 millionen
toten der sowjetunion im zweiten
weltkrieg ursprünglich für den
eigentlichen tag des sieges den neunten
mai geplant war sie corona bedingt
verschoben worden
am tag darauf am kommenden donnerstag
beginnt in russland ein referendum über
die größte verfassungsänderung in der
geschichte des landes
präsident putin plant eine ausweitung
seiner machtbefugnisse
eine zustimmung würde ihm unter anderem
ermöglichen noch bis 2036 im amt zu
bleiben
die vereinten nationen blicken am
freitag auf ihr 75 jähriges bestehen
zurück damals unterzeichneten 50
gründungs nationen die un charta in san
francisco
die organisation sollte den frieden
sichern und die internationale
zusammenarbeit fördern
aktuell besteht sie aus 193 staaten mit
vielen konfliktherden und
eigeninteressen
und jetzt noch die wetteraussichten zum
start in die neue woche
im osten und süden viele wolken und
einzelne schauer sonst überwiegend
sonnig bei 19 bis 26 grad
die weiteren aussichten es bleibt
überwiegend sonnig nur im osten
entwickeln sich einige schauer
die temperaturen steigen bis auf 31 grad
das war für uns weiter geht es mit der
kommissar und das meer und um 0.30 gibt
es dann den nächsten heute express und
hier freuen sich morgen abend christian
sievers und kaiser berichte aus sie noch
einen schönen sonntagabend doch wieder
sehen
[Musik]
was man der frau angetan hatte war
grauenhaft
er hat einen meinem ort eins zu eins
probiert da draußen schlachte dann ihrer
nach meinen romanen leute ab und sieht
mir die leichenteile zu
dieses statement
in den nächste christiane hörbiger ist
die muse des mörders montag 20 15 im zdf
sie zerstören deine karriere sie
betrauen meine freunde
erst in der schule sie haben dich unter
scheint diese parteien müssen auf raten
gerade gefährliche lügen sich und alle
antworten zwar ja ich habe kaufen wollen
montag 22 uhr 15 im zdf
[Musik]